c'est son dernier sommet européen la
démarche est solennel on prend le temps
de saluer ses homologues à c'est l'heure
du bilan aussi ici en cinq ans françois
hollande aura dû gérer des crises crise
financière crise grecque crise des
migrants le break cite justement ce jour
là les vingt-sept ont adopté à
l'unanimité leur stratégie vis-à-vis du
break site les réelles négociations
commenceront après le 8 juin et
s'annonce difficile
alors quand la présidentielle française
prend des allures de référendum pour ou
contre l'europe
françois hollande en profite pour se
livrer à un plaidoyer pro union est le
choix qui posait pour le dimanche 7 mai
c'est de savoir si les français sont
passablement globalement mais
individuellement ont à craindre d'une
sortie de l'union européenne ils ont
tout à gagner à rester dans l'union
européenne de ce point de vue c'est vrai
que l'élection du 7 mai c'est un choix
européen l'occasion aussi d'avertir sur
le saut dans l'inconnu que constituerait
l'élection de marine le pen à la tête de
l'état et de mettre en garde sur les
populistes prend le temps qu'il continue
de le penser
continue de le prévoir continues de 2 le
de préparer ce projet dangereux de
sortie de la france de la zone euro et
de l'union européenne
il le camoufle il le ils le cachent ils
le gomme parce qu'ils savent bien que
les français ne veulent pas que leur
pays sorte de l'union et faut surtout
éviter écarté un risque majeur qui
serait la présence de l'extrême droite à
la présidence de la république
françois hollande quitte le conseil
européen avec le sentiment du travail
accompli
même si son action a souvent été
critiqué pour son manque d'ambition
européenne le 22 juin pour le prochain
conseil européen
ce ne sera pas lui mais son successeur
qui représentera la france au sommet de
bruxelles
[Musique]